utiliser un engin moteur thermique et
mettre son vin en bouteille voici deux
importantes sources de gaz à effet de
serre en viticulture deux talons
d'Achille dont Jean-Baptiste mandar
aimerait un jour se débarrasser pour
rendre son exploitation plus vertueuse
chauffage des locaux c'est chaud
pour devenir un viticulteur
écologiquement responsable il faut
d'abord connaître les problèmes à
résoudre cette tâche incombe à
brioménager conseiller viticole de la
Chambre d'Agriculture de Loir-et-Cher et
expert en diagnostic carbone calculez
l'empreinte en CO2 d'une exploitation
n'est pas obligatoire c'est l'expression
d'une volonté forte et individuelle à
laquelle l'expert offre une réponse
personnalisée
se rendre compte déjà dans un premier
temps quel est son empreinte carbone
voir sur quel levier ils peuvent
s'améliorer justement pour être le plus
vertueux possible
et éventuellement pouvoir communiquer
auprès de leurs clients un petit peu à
leur pas forcément de données chiffrées
mais de pour expliquer à leurs clients
qui sont dans une démarche de vertueuse
concernant le carbone
un cheminement logique pour ce jeune
viticulteur cinquième génération de
vignerons sur ce domaine qui soit y
réduire l'usage des pesticides et
s'interroge face aux effets néfastes du
dérèglement climatique sur les 5
dernières années on a des hausses de
température qui sont qui sont assez
monumentales on a beaucoup de
sécheresses qui nous touchent sur nos
Coto je vois aussi le futur dans un
futur proche et moyen proche où on va
avoir des températures qui vont beaucoup
augmenter qu'est-ce que et comment nos
exploitations dans l'appellation vont
finir par s'en sortir
[Musique]
c'est assez facile à manipuler quand on
a pris le pli pour réduire son empreinte
carbone Aurélie mansois a investi dans
l'électrique cet enjambeur le tracteur a
tout fait en viticulture elle en a fait
l'acquisition il y a quelques mois pour
200.000 euros le prix est un peu
supérieur à un modèle thermique mais les
avantages sont multiples
une vraie révolution c'est c'était un
des freins qui faisait que je voulais
pas forcément passer au travail du sol
parce qu'on consomme beaucoup de
carburant pour travailler des sols le
fait de passer en électrique c'est un
moyen de justement pas avoir ce
bilan carbone négatif parce qu'on fait
beaucoup plus de passage pour travailler
les sols mécaniquement qu'avec un
désherbage chimique
en plus de la Révolution électrique le
domaine adopte toutes les techniques de
l'agriculture durable moins de produits
phytosanitaires et un recours à des
engrais verts pour l'amendement des sols
une évolution qui accompagne celle de
toute la société
on voit bien quand j'ai commencé à faire
travailler le robot on est très regardé
alors à la fois en bien à la fois en mal
parce qu'on a peur avec du machinisme de
perdre un petit peu de son âme ou de son
artisanat ce qui est pas forcément le
cas quand on explique bien les choses
aux gens et qu'on et qu'on leur dit que
c'est pour faire mieux c'est pour faire
plus propre le changement climatique
c'est pas demain c'est tout de suite
c'était presque même hier ça fait deux
trois ans qu'on les prend de plein fouet
et qu'on peut pas faire autrement que
d'agir
demain vous verrez que le changement
climatique fait pousser des cultures
inhabituelles dans le nord de la région
comme de la vigne dans la plaine de
Beauce